Nuclear power today is available,
it produces only very small amounts of
very well confined waste and it does not
contribute to global warming.
This is the reason to better inform the
public why I created Efn,
the Association of Environmental Guess
for Nuclear Energy,
which gathers today over 7,000 members
and supporters in 53 countries.
For more information,
you can refer to our website,
and this is why,
yes,
I consider as an environmentalist that
nuclear energy must absolutely power our
future.
Consider this sizewell B,
which has already been mentioned in
these timeless stores,
its own fuel.
It has about 300 tons of volatile fuel
in a relatively unguarded pond,
relatively calm in comparison with other
parts of the plant.
If the power supply was deliberately
isolated from the plants,
if the emergency generators were
crippled,
the water that keeps that fueled cool
and relatively stable,
what evaporates and the fuel would
explode with horrific consequences.
Now for me,
it's not comforting to think that we'll
never more than a few hours away from a
nuclear explosion.